hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster now the prime
minister is on his way to the G7 in
Japan and Rishi sunak is a man who needs
to leverage all of the power of the
international stage to handle what's
going on back home because after those
local election results labor is a party
with a spring in its step and a
confidence that's allowing kistama to be
bolder on housing and on brexit than has
been before along with the politics we
will also have the very latest on the
car chase involving Prince Harry and
Megan as we bring you takes from all
sides over the next 60 minutes
after 13 years of toryville there's
still lurching from crisis to crisis and
wallowing in their own mess they can't
solve the crisis because they are the
crisis
but with a PM in the air it was the
Battle of the deputies at Prime
Minister's questions Angela Rayna there
and she was up against Oliver Dowden the
third Deputy Prime Minister she's faced
that man there
this comprehensive school boy is not
going to take any lectures from the
party opposite
about the lives of working people
meanwhile we finally got the
long-awaited plans to reform the rental
markets in the UK
now we're making sure that there are
more people in the private rented sector
who have the security of knowing that
they cannot be evicted from their home
well we'll discuss whether those reforms
go far enough plus we'll talk about
British support to Ukraine and much more
with some great guests on the show this
evening first of all we're going to be
hearing from the Armed Forces Minister
James Hep
for labor we'll be speaking to the
shadow schools Minister Stephen Morgan
and will look much more closely at those
reforms to the UK's rental market with a
housing activist question and much more
besides coming up on the tech
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
good evening well as we start the
program this evening I just want to
bring you up to dates on the big
breaking story that we've been covering
on Sky News throughout today Prince
Harry and his wife Megan they've been
involved in what Harry's spokesperson
called a near catastrophic car chase
involving Paparazzi well the couple say
they were chased through New York for
two hours last night or that the city's
mayor said he thought it was hard to
believe that the incident had lasted
longer than 10 minutes you can have a
look now in a statement that the
spokesperson from Prince Harry and Megan
have put out they said that last night
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex and was
Ragland which is better Megan's mother
were involved in a near catastrophic car
chase at the hands of a ring of Highly
aggressive paparazzi
this Relentless Pursuit lasting over two
hours resulted in multiple near
collisions involving other drivers on
the road pedestrians and two NYPD
officers
while being a public figure comes with a
level of interests from the public it
should never come at the cost of
anyone's safety
dissemination of these images given the
ways in which they were obtained
encourages a highly intrusive practice
that is dangerous to all involved
now the couple were in the city for a
charity event a warning that there are
some flashing images in the footage that
we're about to show
well the chase began after Harry and
Megan left the foundation for women
awards ceremony and this was actually
their first public appearance together
since the king's coronation New York
police who were accompanying the
couple's vehicle say the incident was
chaotic
the city's man spoke at a press
conference this afternoon
the Press of paparazzi's you know they
want to get the right shot they want to
get the right story but Public Safety
must always be at the Forefront of my
The Briefing I received uh you know two
of our offices could have been injured
New York City is different
from a small town somewhere you
shouldn't be speeding anywhere but this
is a densely populated city and I think
all of us I don't think there's many of
us who don't recall how
uh how the uh his mom died and it would
be horrific to lose the innocent
bystander during a chase like this and
something to have happened to them as
well I would find it hard to believe
that there was a two-hour high-speed
chase that would be finding hard to
believe but we will find out the exact
duration of it but if it's uh 10 minutes
a 10 minute Chase is extremely dangerous
in New York City we have a lot of
traffic a lot of movement a lot of
people are using our streets of any type
of high-speed chase that involves
something of that nature is
inappropriate
dangerous inappropriate the city's
commenting there and the last few
moments we've also had these words from
Ashley Hansen who is the press secretary
to the Duke and Duchess of Sussex he
said I've never experienced their
vulnerability as much as I did last
night they were incredibly scared and
shaken up
there were several times where the cast
stopped and security got out
there are instances where the police
confronted the paparazzi and had asked
them to stop or give them space to do
this safely unfortunately that wish was
not respected
let's bring in our U.S correspondent
James Matthews James what is the latest
hi Sophie yeah well what we have
essentially are two versions of the same
story and certainly two versions of the
amount of risk that was involved in
developments last night it was clearly
uh an ugly episode
Ugly from the perspective of Harry and
Megan you heard that statement there
from their press secretary they were
pursued for some considerable distance
and according to a statement from their
spokespeople this lasted for two hours
or more it's clear that the bulk of that
time was taken up with Harry and Megan
trying to shake off Paparazzi they had
been at this event organized by The Miz
foundation for women of vision Megan was
being celebrated for her contribution to
gender equality and for human rights it
was when they left that there were
clearly photographers jostling for a
picture they tell their SUV vehicle it
drove around the streets of Manhattan at
that time of night still relatively
crowded for an hour and 15 minutes when
they realized they couldn't shake off
the photographers they headed for a
police station and it was in that police
station having been escorted by an NYPD
police vehicle that they spent around 15
minutes we understand and were switched
into a vehicle at least one vehicle and
at least one taxi at some point it may
be that they made several trips from
that police station because one Taxi
Driver speaks of them getting in the
back of his car he says that he drove
for around 10 minutes from that police
station and there were indeed
photographers the security guard was
unsettled by their presence and within
10 minutes they'd take us back to the
police station police station they did
make an onward Journey eventually from
that station to the private residence of
a friend which is where they were trying
to get to and trying to shake off
photographers so they wouldn't find out
where they were but that taxi driver for
that 10 minute Journey he says this was
nothing like a car chase at that point
he says they seemed unsettled it's no
surprise to him that there had been
unsettling events before they got in to
the car but he never felt in any danger
and did he says the photographers kept a
reasonable distance behind them but he
does say that when the vehicle stopped
photographers took pictures in the
windows in the windows it's clearly a
distressing episode for Harry given his
personal experience Sophie I was at
Balmoral in 1997 the day after his
mother was killed in that Paris car
crash I remember the 12 year old Harry
Ashen faced alongside his brother
William looking at floral tributes to
his mother and he clearly blames the
media for her death and resents the
media for their intrusion into her life
and into his
um I think we have two stories here one
being told by Harry and Megan of
photographers driving on Pavements
breaking red lights going the wrong way
one-way streets and generally
endangering their lives but we have the
New York story backed up by NYPD and the
mayor spoke to it as well they are
stopping well short of describing
anything near anything is near
catastrophic indeed these law
enforcement officials say yes there were
chaotic scenes the NYPD says it was a a
Traffic Challenge they call it
challenging but on the business of it
being near catastrophic that's where
they part with Harry and Megan
thanks very much James and also that
image of course of little Harry in 1997
one that I think I can understand why it
stayed with you and thank you very much
for bringing us the context of that
story we'll of course bring more updates
to you on that breaking news story as
they come in in the meantime though back
to our political interviews because I
did speak to the enforcers minister
James hipie a little earlier and before
moving on to the wider political agenda
today I started our interview by asking
for his reaction to the news about Harry
and Megan
well I mean lots of Sympathy For The
Duke and Duchess of Suffolk and Mrs
Markle um I I I given what happened to
um the Duke of sussex's mother I can
only imagine how harrowing it must have
been for him and
um you know I only know that as much as
I've seen in the sort of breaking news
in the afternoon but
um I can imagine for that him and his
family it must have been
um must be very hiring indeed I'm sorry
to hear that it happened
and the prince's taxpayer fund of
protection was removed when he stepped
back as a senior Royal and left the UK
to go to the United States is that the
kind of thing that maybe should be
re-looked at given what's happened
oh look I think Sophie impossible to
offer that sort of reaction on the fly
when all I've done is seen the the
breaking news I think it's appropriate
to offer my sympathies and to say how I
uh and say how awful it must have been
but without knowing any of the
circumstances impossible to comment on
behalf of the government about what the
security provision what the security
implications may be okay understood as
you say a fast moving story I will be
following lots of developments on that
of course and the defense secretary is
in Germany and discussing continued
support for Ukraine what are the kinds
of things that we're looking at
well I mean he is in Germany to discuss
many things uh not least the uh the
future of NATO there's an important
conference coming up uh in a month or
so's time but any conversation on your
Atlantic security clearly revolves
around what's going on in Ukraine there
is a donor Community uh the UK and
Germany both very prominent within it
that are giving enormous amounts of Kit
to the ukrainians and Ben and Minister
Pistorius will have been having
discussions about what that looks like
as the offensive goes on this summer and
obviously you've seen from Ben's
comments that
um long-range weapons the sort of the
what the the artillery ammunition and
air defense systems and of course
fighter jets are very much the live
conversation
what is the live conversation when it
comes to fighter jets then
well the the I think the conclusion that
ukrainians have come to is that they
would very much like to operate F-16 and
there are a number of nations that
operate F-16 that have indicated a
willingness in principle to provide them
UK doesn't operate F-16 and so what
we've said is that we will assist in the
pilot training pipeline uh to help
Pilots to learn to fly in the first
place and then of course countries that
operate F-16 will need to do the special
to type training thereafter and although
we don't have any of those Jets to
donate ourselves there are clearly
things that we can support uh the
countries that do uh donate those Jets
either through providing some Royal Air
Force capability to backfill any loss
capability on their part or to support
the uh the the maintenance and arming of
those Jets once donated
you talk there about the enormous
support that the UK has offered to
Ukraine and your new procurement
Minister said today the refresh of the
mod's defense reviews of the Defense
command paper should be released by the
end of June are there going to be cuts
to Personnel or equipment in order to
balance the books
well look the the process of looking at
the future of our Armed Forces making
sure that we have properly learned the
lessons from Ukraine uh that all of the
Innovation that we've assisted the
ukrainians in making uh to their uh you
know with their forces and that have had
such effect
um in the fight in Ukraine are quickly
absorbed into the UK Armed Forces as
well so it'd be premature in fact until
the data publication it would completely
completely wrong to say what those
conclusions exactly are but I suspect
that your viewers whatever their concern
may be about the shape size of the Army
Navy Air Force would agree that it is
entirely incumbent on us to a make sure
that everything that we've learned from
Ukraine is reflected as quickly as
possible in our own armed forces and
that b we recognize that since we
published the last Defense command paper
the world has become ever more insecure
and ever more unstable and so we need to
make sure that we are gearing ourselves
against all of those threats and that's
exactly what we're doing uh in the work
we've got going on on the command paper
refresh at the moment
so just stripping away what you're
talking about you're not ruling out Cuts
then are you
no I mean I I'm not ruling tuts out I'm
not ruling increases out I'm saying that
it is we are on a technology Threshold
at the moment there is lots of amazing
things coming into use in all sectors of
the economy with Automation and artistic
artificial intelligence okay computing
power is improving exponentially which
means the ability to sort of crunch data
and thus to Target more effectively
means that something that might
previously have taken 10 artillery guns
and 100 rounds might in the future be
achieved by a couple of guns with 20
rounds that's the order of magnitude of
change that might be possible and what
we're doing in the mod with the
brilliant scientists that we've got in
the defense Science and Technology
Laboratories and with our brilliant
people in defense intelligence is to try
to understand all of those emerging
Technologies as much as we can see how
they've been employed in Ukraine apply
those to our force a big part of the
things that you're looking at
um Rishi sunak is on his way to the G7
in Japan
how helpful do you think it is that his
predecessor Liz truss is at the very
same time giving a speech in Taiwan
making comments about his foreign policy
approach
well Liz is now a back venture and as a
parliamentarian she is entirely in her
right to speak and I think it is you
know when we're faced with the
autocratic oppression that we see from
Putin the idea that a government
Minister should try and say that this
particular Member of Parliament
shouldn't be traveling and saying what
is on her mind
um is clearly not the way we do business
in this democracy the Prime Minister
will go to the G7 and speak for the
nation Liz is in Taiwan uh reflecting
her personal View
understood and there's a couple of
domestic issues that I'll be Keen to get
your view on as well
um and talk about the big changes that
you've made to the rental market today
we'll be talking to a housing campaigner
um quojo later on the program and he
made quite a good point I thought that I
thought that I would steal and put to
you he said local authorities have had
their funding slashed over the last 13
years look at the state of social
housing they are now Under Pressure to
enforce this bill and monitor landlords
will they be given the funding needed to
do this what's your answer to that well
I I can't give you the answer that the
housing Minister would give you
um I sort of
um I can give you a pretty good answer
about the impacts of quantum Computing
on the modern battle space but the exact
detail of Deluxe policy I can't what I
can say it's not a huge I'm you know
look I'm not expecting you to know every
single dotted Iron Cross T in the
housing policy but I think it is a fair
question to say look if you actually
want this to work you're going to need
local authorities to be funded properly
to do it right well before before you
come here that's exactly what I was
going to say I mean I think that
obviously when you bring in any sort of
Reform like this you want to consult
widely and make sure that it is going to
work uh this uh as I understand it is a
proposal that has indeed taken some time
to develop and so I would expect that
the point that your contributor makes is
either one that has already been
considered in the development of the
policy or is something that the
department will be Keen to engage with
to make sure that it is going to work
for local authorities in the way that He
suggests it may not okay understood
um and then just finally there is been a
lot of speculation that net migration
could hit as high as a million next week
this is legal immigration of course
important to make that distinction given
that it's legal should we be relaxed
about how high that number goes
well I think that there has been uh a
lot of effort in government to make sure
we shut down on illegal migration that
is the bit that I think the public react
to as being unfair inappropriate and
it's right that they expect their
government to control their borders as
for what our requirements are when it
comes to Legal migration I think there
are lots of economic Arguments for why
we do need Workforce to meet the needs
of certain sectors but clearly we have
to also make sure that we are not
missing the opportunity to improve our
productivity and drive Innovation into
our workplace by taking advantage of
cheap migrant labor now my senses from
what I've seen of the debate playing out
within government that that is very much
the balance that the government is
trying to strike I think it's invidious
to say that a certain number is too much
or that there should be a ceiling or
that we should be aiming for a Target
that is significantly lower we should do
what is needed for our economy whilst
recognizing that the answer to a labor
shortage isn't always more migration
actually focusing on issues of
productivity and Automation and
technology in the workplace is similarly
important
really good to talk to you thank you for
being on the show thank you very much
indeed thank you
I thought that final answer on the
debates about migration really
interesting actually clearly a live
debate going on as James hippie
acknowledges within government about
those upcoming net migration figures
expected to be uh pretty high be
interesting to see what the actual
responses when they do come out you're
watching the take we're live here in
Westminster for you up next we're going
to get Labor's view with the shadow
School swinster
foreign
[Music]
ified effort with our European allies to
show our strong support for Ukraine but
also to
condemn Russia in as loud and as strong
a voice as we can in the U.S is very
much a part of that and we support the
efforts of our European colleagues and
want to make sure that Ukraine knows it
has it has our support we have seen the
destruction
that Russia has wrought on the Ukrainian
people we see the missiles every day
bombing buildings and bumming their
infrastructure and they have to be held
accountable for that and the registry is
one step toward laying that Foundation
of accountability so that in the future
we have the mechanism we have the legal
basis for holding Russia accountable
well of course they're not going to
recognize it they don't recognize that
they are committing acts of uh they're
committing war crimes they're committing
human rights violations what they are
doing is unconscionable and we have to
start the process of holding them
accountable and and have them in
particular with this registry be called
to the mat to pay for the damages that
they have caused we have worked with
with our colleagues both at the U.N and
here in in Europe to find a basis that
is supported by the majority and we're
here and we are speaking with one voice
and we know that Ukraine appreciates
that and we know that Russia hears us
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hello welcome back live to Westminster
watching the take and it's been another
pack day in Westminster we've had the
long-awaited rental reform proposals
from the government the kind of thing
that really impacts people's lives and
the battle of the deputies at pmqs plus
much more just besides in the last
couple of days let's take a quick look
back shall we at some of the highlights
of the political week so far
Ukraine's president zielinski's paid a
surprise visit to the UK meeting prime
minister Rishi sinak at his country
residence Checkers it's been really good
for us to have the time to talk together
in private about the support that the UK
is giving to create these uh Jets
Coalition and I'm very positive with it
just want to bring you
um some video we have from Westminster
this took place at the national
conservatism conference which kicked off
today I would like to draw your
attention to
a few characteristics of fascism
talking at the rcn's annual conference
Pat Cullen warned that nurses strikes
could go on until Christmas prime
minister
you did the right thing to open
negotiations with me in February
before the 75th birthday of the NHS this
July let's get the job finished I'm
important to stress just how rare these
Council of Europe Summits oh this is the
first time this is happening more than a
decade in 15 years it's only happened
four times since this group was set up
after the second world war we must also
learn the lessons of this war
by being prepared to confront threats to
our societies before they become too big
to deal with
that includes acting on cyber security
and AI
and it means tackling illegal migration
[Laughter]
and you know what they say the third
time's a charm and I'm also pleased to
note Mr Speaker that the Prime Minister
as a working-class friend finally
it really is a pleasure to see the right
honorable lady here today I was though
expecting to face the labor leaders
choice for the next Deputy Prime
Minister if they win the election so I'm
surprised that the lib Dem leader isn't
taking questions
[Applause]
they were enjoying that weren't they uh
let's get the view from labor now shall
we I'm joined live by the parties Shadow
schools Minister uh Stephen Morgan first
time on the program good to have you uh
here thank you for coming in
um it looked like they had a bit of a
laughter uh Deputy Prime Minister's
questions what do you think from the
from the room they did it was a bit
spikier compared with usual but I think
Angelo Reynold always has a brilliant
job speaking up for our country uh now I
want to talk to you about housing policy
because this is really feels to me like
it's getting out to be one of the big
Battlegrounds for the next election
labor is quite controversially saying it
could build on the Green Belt just it
can you just explain what that means
what is the green belt for our viewers
who might not understand well I think
it'd be fair to say that we've got a
housing crisis in our country and it
absolutely is an important issue that I
hear on the doorstep all the time in my
own constituency 2 000 people are
waiting on the council's waiting list
for a home the government Target used to
be for 17 and a half thousand more homes
in Portsmouth in a really densely
populated city what key is set out today
I think is our intentions to say a lot
more on this in future that we need to
make some tough choices about reforming
the planning system and making sure we
build the homes that our country needs
and I think that's the right approach
and as he said he could be on the side
of businesses and on the side of
Builders not on the side of blockers the
question students about the Greenback
though right and the kind of buffer if
you like between the countryside and
urban areas that many people think is
quite important to stop you know an
urban sprawl you know Kirsten told me
recently that he would take on the
nimbies but is that a bit dismissive of
some people who might have genuine
concerns about their local area well
it's really important that people have
their say in communities are absolutely
instrumental in that and that's why
we've got all Take Back Control build
that Lisa and Andy's been setting out
and she's been engaging with communities
up and down the country you know but
we've got to find ways of building homes
in our country it's desperately needed
the way that we live is changing and I
think we've got to make sure that local
authorities and communities have their
saying these important decisions you say
communities have their say but I mean
that's not completely what you're saying
is that you're saying that actually it's
important to build homes just even on
areas like the green belt well what I
know about some of the consultation
around home building is that sometimes
the communities get involved too late in
the day and actually we need to bring
forward the ways that communities have
their say much earlier on okay now
teachers are strong thing I'm not I'm
going to ask you what labor would do but
can I just ban the phrase that you want
to get around the table because I feel
like that's a given right we know you
want to get around the table I want to
know what you're going to say when you
get around the table so teachers have
and turn down a 4.3 pay rise what would
labor do well the first thing to say is
that teachers are overworked they're
under huge stress and I think they're
undervalued and I think the government
have not done enough to negotiate a deal
you know I won't say it but we certainly
do want to see don't say it come on Fair
Deal what is a fair deal then what is a
fair well it's really different everyone
wants to see a fair deal but everyone
has different definitions of what a fair
deal is right really difficult for us to
say when we're not in government we
don't have the information available to
us but we've got to listen and engage to
teachers they do tremendous we want to
get around the table I've got it but
what do you want to do what do you want
to do what keeps me awake at night
Sophie is the fact that so many teachers
are leaving the profession you know
they've joined the profession they've
got the chance to transform children's
lives but within a few years they leave
because they're demoralized the workload
is too great pays really important there
are other things as well and that's why
I'm talking to teachers on a regular
basis to find out what they'd want to
see from an incoming labor government
and that's my priority I mean I think
what a lot of teachers would like to say
it's more pay right so what would labor
give them more pay well look at what we
did in government last time and we
transformed our nation schools and pay
Rose by 19 under the last Labor
government we completely
professionalized the teaching profession
and people joined that job it was a
brilliant job for people to do we want
to recruit more teachers so I'm
absolutely committed to talking to trade
unions to teachers and others I was in a
school this morning hearing what their
concerns are I think more flexible
working is when the answers to their
problems that they face I read an
interview with Rachel reads recently
where she was talking about how she
wouldn't send her children to private
school because she was saying that she
wants them to see the world as it is
what's your view on private education I
want to see every child in every part of
our country going to brilliant local
school of course that's a given right
but what is your view on private
education well we've been really clear
that we need to make some tough choices
about how schools are funded and we
think it's only fair that we end the tax
breaks that private schools enjoy that
will generate 2.2 to Berlin that would
go into the state sector and would do
some really transformative things to
improve outcomes for all young people do
you think that people who go to private
school don't see the world as it is
I think that parents make the choice
that they think's best for their child
it wouldn't be a choice that I would
make but ultimately that's the choice
that some parents do choose to make
um now I just want to talk to you a bit
about brexit because it seems to me that
Kirsten has been pretty Punchy about
breakfast about brexit today I said
breakfast there that's such a classic
classic brexit slip of the tongue there
and so to my colleague in King for
example he said he would be open to
renegotiation there's lots of things
that he wants to do including closer
trading so would labor see a much closer
relationship with the EU than the
current government then well as a
remainer I didn't want to see brexit
happen but I accepted the outcome of the
referendum wanted to put that back for
people but lost the argument at the last
gen election what key is set out is
obviously a five-point plan that we want
to break down the barriers for trade
want as close as possible relationship
with the EU I think that's the right
approach we need to move on we need to
make brexit work to smooth over the
edges and get the best for our country
you've ruled out rejoined the EU you
said that you lost the argument the last
election and to have another referendum
you've also ruled out with Jordan the
single Market
I just wonder about the Customs Union
because it strikes me that look the big
issue that some would say with the
Customs Union and she can't strike your
own trade deals but you know would you
say that the trade deals that we have
managed to get with other countries have
outweighed that that we could have as
part of the Customs Union
well I think what we're seeing with some
of the trade deals is there's not much
detail there at all and that's why you
know we want to see a labor government
to have a close possible relationship
with the European Community looking at
the Customs Union under a labor
government well we're really clear that
we want to see much closer relationship
with Europe we're set out a lot more
detail on our policies ahead the next
election
what about the Customs Union I know I'm
asking you to make you know you don't
want to give I mean it's not not my
brief of course what I want to do is to
make sure we hold the current government
to account for their failings on brexit
and we get the best possible deal for
our economy and create the jobs that our
country so desperately needs okay thank
you very much it's great to have you on
the program today thank you thank you
so there you go that was uh Labor's tape
we can have a little chat now to our
Deputy political editor Sam coats who
was uh standing by for us at the wall um
Sam I know you your ears were kind of
pricky up a little bit weren't they
about what Kirsten was saying on brexit
what's your take on that that's right
you had kissed almost speaking to Ian
King earlier he talked about breaking
down barriers about negotiating real
improvements uh with our relationship
with the EU now
in power this is simply a sign of
Labor's confidence in politics at the
moment because for many many months
actually the local party wasn't terribly
Keen uh to talk about the relationship
with the EU for for fear of kind of
Reviving some of the old arguments that
hurt them at the last election and I
think right now actually you're seeing a
reinvigorated labor party back up going
up again in the polls feeling like it
can talk about this stuff so I think
that's the first important thing now in
the past they've been worried about the
Tories response and the Tories have come
out and said that they're laid possible
to rig British elections by allowing EU
citizens to vote reopen the brexit deal
hand power to Brussels and surrender
uncontrolled unlimited immigration
that's the round that you're hearing
almost all of that is untrue the labor
party have walked back from the idea of
getting EU Nationals to vote to say that
they don't want unlimited uncontrolled
immigration and all parties want to
renegotiate brexit because that's in the
legislation that's happening anyway in
2025-26 so my question is do you think
that labor are going a bit further as
you say than they would have on brexit
because they're more confident that they
can say what they thought all along or
because they are actually sensing that
something is Shifting when it comes to
practicing the public view on it I think
that you're hearing the arguments about
brexit that little bit louder what
you're hearing from kierstama today in
technical terms was in a speech by David
Lammy a few months ago but you didn't
hear it Amplified by the party it's the
confidence that means that's happening
now loudly and in public and it is going
to mean if this mountain Downing Street
a close relationship with Europe he
wants to do a kind of deal with the EU
on kind of food and agriculture
standards which will stuff trade deals
frankly uh he wants to do specific deals
on specific sectors like cars
um now the problem that he's got is that
this man wants the good bits the EU some
of the zero tariff agreements the fact
you don't have to pay when you transfer
goods and it's easy to do without some
of the commitments uh the need for
freedom of movement for instance which
kirst armor has ruled out that is cherry
picking so the danger for labor is if
they get into power they may have
aspirations for a closer deal but
they'll find themselves the problems
that Britain has had all the way along
since brexit which is you can't have the
good bits and not have the obligations
it's interesting because we always talk
about
um EU and Labor's issues of the EU
on domestic audience right you know
how's it going to go down in the red
wall but actually as you say it could be
the round with Brussels that is even
more important if here's a number 10.
thanks very much for your analysis we'll
have more from Sam later in the program
in the meantime we are live in
Westminster for you this evening up next
we're going to be taking a closer look
at those all-important reforms to the
rental market
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
hello welcome back live to Westminster
you're watching the take well let's turn
back now to a story that we have been
discussing a bit throughout the program
it's plans to scrap so-called no-fault
evictions in England they've been
unveiled today as part of a long promise
shake-up of the rental market well
housing campaigners say the government's
renters Reform Bill is a huge
opportunity to improve the lives of
millions of tenants our political
correspondent Liz Bates reports
for England's 11 million renters life
can be difficult I've been forced to
move three times since the start of the
pandemic through a combination of
no-fault evictions so like section 21s
and rent Rises now a change in the law
is coming that the government size will
help people like Jasmine by ending no
fault evictions I feel like more needs
to be done I feel like the bill doesn't
go far enough I say that because
um the way that I've been forced out
each time is it may have come with a
section 21 notice but in the end you
know uh I've been advised there's no
point in fighting your section 21 notice
if you can't afford to pay the rent
increase housing secretary Michael Gove
has insisted he is on the side of
renters and the plans will give more
powers to people like Belinda who says
her landlord has repeatedly refused to
fix mold and leaks and threatened her
with eviction the good news is that even
at a time when people are facing real
pressure on their household budgets that
rents and private rented sector have
risen less than inflation and of course
in this legislation we affirm that rents
can only rise once a year and if rents
are thought to be unfair there's an
ombudsman now that we're creating
the bill will also give landlords new
powers to evict tenants that are
anti-social or behind on their rent it
will bring in new standards that Force
landlords to keep their properties safe
and well maintained and it will end
blanket bans on people on benefits or
with children
but some critics including conservative
MPS say it will drive landlords out of
the sector he was given to keys and
there's one two three four five six
seven front door keys Lisa has
experienced a problem tenant and has
used a no-fault eviction when he didn't
pay his rent I issued the section 21.
and which I'm very glad I did but he
didn't go out on the date he was he
lived there rent free for six months but
when she found out this law change was
coming she felt she had no choice but to
sell it really does force your hand and
I decided to sell and I'm pretty sure
there's going to be quite a few
landlords doing the same thing and
selling
housing campaigners have called the
legislation a huge opportunity but with
house building targets scrapped and
Rising interest rates will it be enough
to fix the crumbling foundations of
Britain's rental market Liz Bates Sky
News North London
really feels like housing it's going to
be such a key Battleground doesn't it in
politics really impacting so many people
well I can speak now to somebody who has
experienced firsthand some of the issues
in the UK's housing system and has since
become one of the country's most
prominent housing activists crochet
twentyboa it's great to have you on the
program and it was last year that we
lost babe wasn't it it was um and kojo
is someone who has the ear of government
you always in and out meeting people and
just just to introduce produce yourself
to viewers who might not be familiar
with yourself and the kind of
campaigning you do why did you end up
being drawn into this kind of activism
well I started off well I was I live in
social housing and I was living in poor
quality social housing with my sisters
and my dad and we were complaining to
our landlord at the time who just simply
didn't listen my dad became ill with
cancer passed away in those conditions
and I had to turn to social media in
order to disgrace my landlord not only
my landlord but other social housing
tenants landlords to into carrying out
necessary works I know you're the sort
of person who is always amplifying the
voices of other people who are currently
living in these conditions but just
describe the conditions that you and
your family I mean damp mold cockroaches
mice we have a kitchen that was nearly
100 years old poor security we had
lights filled with water you name it I
mean the list goes on and since then
I've been contacted by people in social
housing but also the private sector too
living in slum conditions in a lot of
cases whilst paying extortionate rents I
mean we know around 3.2 million people
have said in the private sector they
have lived at some point in disrepair I
think it's really important to talk to
people like yourself actually because I
do think that there is a tendency in the
Westminster bubble whether it's
journalists politicians you name it for
people to reflect on their own
experiences right and actually that's
not always the norm and what people are
actually experiencing as you say like
across the country
what do you make of what the comments do
today do you think it's going to help I
definitely think it's going to help I
mean it's a long time coming people have
been asking and begging for um changes
and regulation the renters Reform Bill
for the private sector for a very very
long time so it's very
um welcomed especially with the ban on
no fault evictions that's something
people have campaigned on for so long
and just the idea of tenants being
evicted with no reason in a lot of cases
I mean for shelter for example there was
a hundred and forty three percent
increase in no fault evictions in the
last year alone so that just goes to
show how big of a problem it is and the
introduction of an ombudsman service for
example I mean with the scrap of no
fault eviction that doesn't mean that
landlords can't still evict tenants I
wanted to make that clear because I
think there has been some confusion what
it means is they have to have a valid
reason in order to do so having said
that with this legislation I definitely
think at the moment there are current
loopholes for example yes we're
scrapping section 21 but what we're
seeing is landlords can still evict
tenants for example if they want to move
a family member in or if they default on
their rental payments now what can
happen in this situation with bad
landlords they can then choose to up the
rent for example make it so unaffordable
tenants default and then evict them that
way or for example just say they're
going to move a family member in and
then the tenants have to have to move
out so the government definitely needs
to tighten up these loopholes to make
sure if landlords are evicting tenants
they're for the right reason and they're
honest about it you made the points
about funding yes as well and say that
there needs to be funding for
enforcement for this to work
um absolutely I mean that's my biggest
point I think it's all good and well
having this all written on paper and
having this bill discussed in Parliament
but fundamentally what we're relying on
in order to regulate this is local
authorities now with local authorities
we've seen them underfunded over the
last 13 years massively we've seen the
state of social housing run by some
local authorities and now what we're
asking is for them to manage 2 2.2
million landlords to I think the biggest
challenge for Michael Gove now is um
whether or not he can get the funding to
do so if the department for leveling up
doesn't have it then he has to go to the
chancellor and prime minister and
convince them that that is the right
decision to make just a bit more widely
as well it feels that there's a big
debate going on in Western about house
building and whether or not it should be
on the Green Belt whether or not local
people's concern should be overridden
what's your take on that from what I've
seen as a campaigner over the last two
years and the conditions people are
having to live in the rates of
homelessness people in temporary
accommodation
um I understand people's concerns
especially about the green belt but
simply we have a crisis here and a
crisis that has existed for decades we
need more homes if that means
unfortunately that we we have to build
and put on pockets in the green belt
then I absolutely think we need to
because what is that other alternative
we need more homes fundamentally
and then just a bit more what it is
about on the cost of living
um
it always shocks me when I look at
rental inflation right and also the
percentage of people's pay packets that
they end up spending on rent what is
going on in the private rental sector do
you think people are really really
struggling I mean I've spoken to
um tenants that I have to borrow off
their kids because they simply cannot
afford on their wages to pay for their
rent bills fuel bills and everything
else on top of that we've seen how much
food for example has gone up and um they
are really really struggling at the
moment I think what is kind of ironic
for me is the fact that government is
talking about home ownership and pushing
home ownership whilst we're in a cost of
living crisis and people are struggling
to pay their rents and rents especially
in London are currently unaffordable for
so many in terms of one bedroom for
example one thousand pounds per month is
their average if people can't afford to
save how does the government expect them
to get on the ladder and especially
during a cost of living crisis too when
people are struggling that's the issue
you need to or they need to be dealing
with is bottom-up approach not top down
and what you make of Labor's sort of
policies on it do you have optimism I
guess yes I mean it's really really
interesting I think from both parts to
see them talking about housing for a
long time I don't think it's been
discussed enough I think housing is
becoming very very prominent and will be
huge at the next general election
whether or not they are going to make
the right decisions and focus on the the
things that people are calling for most
um is still up for debate I think but I
really really hope they do listen to the
people if they're going to create
well-informed policies they need to be
informed by people affected currently by
the current situations it's always
really interesting to talk to you thanks
very much for taking the time out this
evening thank you really interesting
stuff you're watching at the take could
definitely agree that I think housing is
going to be a key issue at the next
election next up we are going to be
rounding up everything that we've heard
so far and do a bit of place match
analysis with our Deputy political
editor Sam Kates
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
how are you feeling
strong
one Almighty crush it was like night
foul
can you hear that Mark the game is he's
going to have to stand down the Majesty
Queen Elizabeth II has died against the
dollar ever ever I am resigning hopes of
reaching Britain dashed at least for
today
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
political editor who's here again we're
just discussing weren't we
um how refreshing it is to hear from
people at quojo who really are
passionate about things about housing
reform in a keen to try and make change
that's right and we are effectively now
in really the very very early start of
the run-up to a general election and so
putting in those bids for change uh
working through the argument making your
promises is is kind of the name of the
game at the moment and we were just sort
of stepping back earlier in the office
and just having a look at just how much
change there might be very imminently
now here in the UK we're expecting a
general election next year we don't know
whether it's going to be May whether
it's going to be July whether it's going
to be October or even later in the year
but that could be massive and it could
see the UK installed potentially if the
results are anything like the local
elections the first
non-conservative Prime Minister in 14
years 14 years that's huge which is huge
but then pull the camera out and look
all around the world it turns out safely
that next year is the year of Elections
they're everywhere so in November
there'll be a U.S election quite
possibly Donald Trump versus Joe Biden
could it be Donald Trump back in the
white house or would it be this guy will
it will he be able to stop Donald Trump
returning and it'll be the the biggest
Revenge second second act that you have
ever seen then in addition there's
Europe now there are European
parliamentary elections uh in June now
they're important for us actually
because off the back of that you get to
choose a new European commission they
will determine the kind of brexit deal
that we have when the next prime
minister or Rishi sunak comes into
Downing Street and determines exactly
how how we interact with the European
Union there is even an Indian set of
Elections next year at some point for
one of the most populous countries in
the world all together next year I
calculated that 1.4 billion people are
going to go to the polls over the course
of that year we could end up with a very
different world at the end of 2024 and
the one that we begin with that's hugely
I can't actually really get my head
around what that means the number of
people who are going to be voting I mean
that is that is
also does really mean doesn't it as you
say that it's quite an unpredictable
period when you have all of that change
across the world it's quite difficult to
work out the small changes that can
suddenly spark something that actually
is a fundamental is the world going to
return to the sort of center-ground
politics maybe the late 1990s early
2000s is the world going to move to
extremes more popular Solutions or are
there going to be no patterns at all
that's going to be the exciting question
for 2024 it's a bit early for people to
start thinking about it places like this
we've got to start thinking about it
because the change involved is massive
and some of those elections quite
unpredictable as well we don't even know
who's going to be running in all of them
um Sam thanks very much indeed as always
for your analysis that's it for the take
we'll be back next week and every week
on Wednesdays at 9 00 PM next up it is
Sky News at 10. thanks very much for
watching
foreign